let's start last week some very positive
news from Scotland Yard they said that
they believe there's a reasonable chance
of Madeleine still being alive and they
identified nearly 200 leads that were
worth following up what was your
reaction to that very positive news well
I guess we've always said the first
point you made there we know there's a
real possibility that modern can still
be found alive but I guess for us it was
important to hear the police saying that
after they've reviewed the evidence or
you know at least part of the way
through the evidence I think yeah it's
excellent and it's the most hopeful I
think we've been since the early days to
be honest Martin and at this point we
know there's tremendous resource I'm
very experienced team reviewing all the
information and I committed team with
Detective Chief Inspector Vega its
leading who really want to find
Madeleine and what happened so if anyone
does of information evidence this is the
tank to come forward and we really are
for their the police optimism was based
on what they identified as opportunities
in which an abductor could have taken
Madeleine well that really wasn't
anything new because you've always said
that between your regular checks on the
children there were opportunities but we
were told privately that there's other
information that rather corroborates the
idea that Madeleine could still be alive
are you aware of what else there is
well understanding has always been that
there's no evidence to suggest she's
come to harm and that means there's
always a realistic possibility that in
combined with the fact that many other
children have been
after a very prolonged periods of
abduction and it's probably what they
emphasize in as well I mean the younger
a child's taken often have been taken to
be kept and Madeleine's and that you
know a lot younger than their normal
child has taken you know for sexual
reasons I mean we are aware that new
information has come in and also that
new things have been identified within
the material that's already there that
haven't yet been investigated I mean
obviously we hear about things in broad
terms rather than specifics to be honest
but obviously it's given us a lot of
hope and I guess I'm not surprised
because I've been through the files you
know I've seen things have kind of the
Gaussian you know that needs to be
locked out but it's just good to have
you know a team on board who were really
determined to find it and yet after that
optimism we got that response from the
attorney general's office in portugal
it's his decision about reopening the
investigation that there was no new
facts he talked about hypotheses and
speculation how did that make you feel
just there's a - for that so I do
believe that as new information there's
information that we've seen this coming
directly to us and it's been passed on
so we strongly believe that there is new
information I think how you treat some
of the more historical things and
identifying links there may be
difference of opinion but ultimately a
lot of the investigative opportunities
lie in Portugal and inevitably to carry
those out properly into fulfillment then
the case will have to be reopened and
while Madeline's missing and the
perpetrator said at large then the case
will need to be reopened do you think it
will be reopened I think it will enjoy
of course I mean I think you know short
of someone coming forward and saying
here she is
you know our best chance of finding it
and also the person who's committed the
crime is by reopening the case so you
know hopefully given time a human that
everybody wants to find Madeline and
wants to find the perpetrator then you
know I am hopeful that the case will be
reopened I don't think anybody expected
the Portuguese authorities within 24
hours to announce the opening I mean how
far do you accept that there are
complicated diplomatic niceties that
have to be overcome you know we weren't
expecting an overnight reaction we've
been in this situation for three and a
half years it took us a long time to get
the review that if you is not finished
and let's not forget that so those are
investigative opportunities almost 200
have come from the first twenty thousand
pages so we're quite happy for the
Metropolitan Police to be lazing with
the Portuguese authorities going through
the proper process and presenting the
evidence and and real opportunities and
I think they'll make a very very strong
case and and it makes a tremendous
difference that it's not don't us we do
we felt we got on our own for a very
long time and it doesn't feel like that
anymore I really feel that the UK
authorities in the Metropolitan Police
in particular really want to get to the
bottom of this one hundred and ninety
five leads could be interpreted as 195
missed opportunities any parent would
feel very angry to learn that after a
review of a quarter of the material
there are nearly 200 chances of clues
what what do you do with that anger
because we got to a point now where we
we just want to go forward we can't we
can't change it but whilst it can be
done you know
let's do it in some ways it's great that
those leads are there because it gives
us something to work with which is why
we know campaign petition for three and
a half years to get better view in the
first place we knew if the case was just
reopened people be standing there going
okay now what do we do but at least with
having that of you and having these
actions identified the stuff to work
yeah you know most everybody the
mistakes have been well publicized and
we know there was resource issues and
just that the data capturing and
different things and we also know that a
lot of the the police everyone they try
you know the war is a big investigation
but it's actually better to know that
there are still opportunities for us and
we just want those to be performed
reasonably as any family would for a
missing child or a serious crime that's
been committed you want to get to the
bottom of it and bring those responsible
to justice when you look at this age
progressive picture of madelung at nine
what do you see actually see Madeleine
to be honest and it's strange because
although it's a market of how many years
have passed
as a silo cur and I can see it in it and
and again that gives me home because I
think you know I just want everyone to
look at it take a good long hard look at
it and circulate it to as many people as
possible because I mean I do believe
it's a good resemblance of what she
looks like
today and and I think it can be a really
useful tool for the investigation
discipline great job really must be a
bit difficult to look at the daughter
you haven't seen for nearly five years
what are your things I mean I don't
think I don't look at to think that is
Madeleine we know it's a resemblance I
don't think of it as modeling the
important thing is challenging their
assumption that Madeleine as a
four-year-old who's been you know who's
frozen in time she's not she will have
changed and the public will also know
very forgiving in terms of resemblance
damages and particularly children they
look at these pictures in a very
different way so we know from American
particular that these images work a lot
at the time what a room Sean and Emily's
reaction to to see Polly when we would
start in the drafts that they artists
and it hasn't changed that much from the
original draft actually that's how close
I think Tony was when she did it but we
showed it to them and we
how old is this little girl is and they
said older the north I said okay so how
old and listen all eight maybe nine so
what she after that we actually tweaked
it to make it look a little bit older
but and they said is this is that
Madeline and I said all this is what we
think she might look white now so you
know they're not up to speed with
everything and they understand why we've
done that how are you going to mark
tomorrow the fifth anniversary
well Joe Joe reason in work to be honest
I've got a month I'm gonna go to you for
Madeline I'm spending the day with a
friend and then ask you've done the last
few years it'll be a service for
Madeline I mean the will be in seven
places to be honest and you know I'll be
with family friends and supporters and
I guess one of your abiding thoughts at
times like this well all the time I
suppose is that somebody knows what
happened yeah what would you say to
whoever it is and there must be somebody
what would you say to them after five
years it's the same message it's just
not too late you know please let us know
you know tell us where she is
tell us what's happened if you think you
know you know who's done it if it's your
brother if it's your son your colleague
please do the right thing you know and
it's not too late it's really not that
snow you've said in the past that you
were very concerned that you were alone
in searching for Madeleine that appears
to have changed now how encouraged are
you by that
it's how to emphasize how important the
differences between this time last year
and more well I've no sense the the
review was granted and the men and the
resource and experience that brought to
bear and we do we don't feel like what
on Iran anymore and their times and the
past we have felt like has been bottle
after bottle and now we really feel that
the British authorities are committed
absolutely committed
it's taken a tremendous button away from
Kate and I on Madeleine's fund and
everyone else around us we're really
grateful to the Metropolitan Police and
we're also really grateful to the
general public because without their
support I didn't think we'd ever got the
review island and from the review to a
re-investigation how confident are you
that that will happen soon I don't know
when but I mean obviously we hope it
will happen soon you know we want to
find Madeline we want to find out what's
happened we want to find who's
responsible for the crime and I think
the sooner we start looking at these
needs and getting invest getting an
investigation going the better really if
you don't look you won't find do you
have any idea what those leads are what
the important perhaps the more important
of those leads is we know what quite a
few of them are but I wouldn't say by
any means we've been through 195 care
identified many many of them are self as
you would expect but the police are
confident that these are actionable and
some of them are you know highest
priority so that's encouraging
okay thank you thanks very much Thank
You Martin thank you